[Musique]
oui
plug in love donc c'est une plateforme
de collaboration entre les laboratoires
de recherche publique de l'université
paris 5 c et les entreprises
le but c'est de faciliter la connexion
entre ces deux acteurs sur le territoire
paris saclay donc le village est un
outil donc une plateforme web qui est
son poids sur un moteur de recherche par
mots clés ou par thématique par domaines
d'innovation
on peut ainsi accéder à tout potentiel
de recherche les expertises des
compétences les équipements de
l'université paris saclay donc ça donne
accès aux utilisateurs et notamment aux
pme potentiel d'innovation des
laboratoires de la recherche ce qui peut
être
fils il entrevoit donc cette plateforme
offre un point d'entrée unique sur tout
ces expertises pour chaque laboratoire
et chaque plateforme technologique dont
par mots clés on peut trouver facilement
des compétences ou des équipements si
j'entre par exemple pollution la base va
aller nous chercher tous les
laboratoires qui corresponde à ce mot
clé et on accède rapidement au plus des
laboratoires qui correspondent à la
recherche et par exemple sur cette fiche
laboratoire on va avoir rapidement les
informations sur laboratoire de manière
synthétique pour comprendre un peu ce
que fait le laboratoire et on a la
possibilité d'observer
l'offre de technologie qui propose pour
évaluer un peu son potentiel
d'innovation
il ya également possibilité de les
contacter directement depuis la
plateforme en utilisant ce simple bouton
pour contacter le responsable soit du
laboratoire soit la plateforme
technologique
donc c'est un site qui est disponible en
version française mais également en
version anglaise sur ne se limitent pas
au territoire paris saclay le but c'est
vraiment que tout utilisateur d'où qu'il
vienne puisse entrevoir le potentiel de
nuitées paris s'inquiète ses
laboratoires jeunes cet outil plus
qu'une simple plateforme internet c'est
également une équipe derrière qui permet
de répondre aux besoins qui nous sont
adressées quand la mise en relation ne
se fait pas facilement
il ya parfois besoin de travailler de
leurs besoins technologiques de
l'entreprise et ainsi l'entreprise peut
nous contacter directement et al assad
paris saclay on est chargé de dd à
répondre aux besoins technologiques et
donc si il n'est pas évident par la
simple recherche sur ces laboratoires
sur ses fiches synthétiques de trouver
réponse à un besoin
on va aller creuser derrière pour vous
aider à trouver quelque chose de plus
convenable quelque chose qui correspond
vraiment à votre besoin d'innovation
[Musique]